[Music]
in 3 2
action so good good good
[Music]
good you love bad name anyone but him I
didn't approve him you know that you are
literally the last person on Earth I
want to see slap the [__] out of you I
really could and I'm open to that in a
safer
[Music]
environment you been a ghost no phone
call no
text it's not like I didn't want to
apologize you don't have to explain
anything it was just a
flame so how have you
been God I hate that thumbs up stunky
stuff I'm the director we're going to
set this man on fire you're a stunk guy
we need to keep it super profes profess
is my middle name he said your middle
name was
danger how do we do
boss really yeah holster that it's
Holsted it's done forget you you never
saw
it Tom
Ryder the biggest action star on the
planet is missing you need to bring him
back B J's movie is dead why me you're a
stump man nobody's going to notice you
that's your job no offense I'm mean some
taken you find Ryder save Jody's film
you get the love of your life back I'm
not the hero I'm just a double not today
you're
not Tom we only need you back on set
pal oh
dead body on Ice he was so dead Gail he
was super
dead he has got himself involved with
some shady
people I had no choice I had to do some
Jason boor
[__] they were trying to kill
me and not in a fun way you making you
br it you can't make it it's too
dangerous got me
stairs
what happened to your face you look
terrible you look
amazing you fall down you get right back
up how far would you go for the one that
you
love I'll BL you drink when this is over
engage your
core yeah
boy what you doing later want to go to a
beach somewhere drink a spicy Margarita
make some bad decisions yes
oh the heart and you're
[Applause]
to when I
sleep I see strange
[Music]
things
memories
not
Memories new
things I see
everything that is
not
[Music]
everything
what a wonderful
day I certainly hope you dance as well
as you
dress there's only one way to find
out
put on
your dance the you and I we're not so
different agent
Ary little help hold
[Music]
on the book is phenomenal sweetie
but what happens next it's called a
cliffhanger mother H it's called call
the cop
[Music]
out whoa hey there's a cat in
there oh my God you're Ellie freaking
Conway author of ARG series Ellie
Conway I am such a fan oh yeah what does
it you do Espionage would you sign my
book here we
go I love this book
come
[Music]
on who are these people real life spies
why would they care about me because
you're a goddamn fortune teller Ellie
why see what you wrote in your new book
actually happened and you kicked the
hornet nest you didn't even know existed
I'm in some really big trouble mom
what oh so now you're experimenting with
drugs I want all assets on them now I
need her to write the next
chapter God I hate that
[Music]
cat it's it's time for you to meet the
real agent
Argy oh my God oh my God oh my
[Music]
God you're a blessing Mr Clay this place
was crab grass and weeds and you brought
it back to life
Mrs Parker and I were friends she was
like family she was the only person who
ever took care of
me I just got a message saying that
there's a problem with my computer yes
ma'am we got
this here today she shot herself this is
private property do you know what they
do here scamming the weakest in our
society buddy I'm counted three 1 2
3 there I did it for you
no you it I'm going to burn this place
to the
ground will you stomp his ass
out you're telling me one man did this
the only thing you know is he a
beekeeper a beekeeper beekeeper well
that's not
good beekeepers is a special program
outside the chain of command I protect
the hive when the system is out of
balance I correct it we have wars for
these things until they fail then you
have
me my fingers he cut them off what the
[__] bro don't
move Bow
Down is much bigger than a little
fishing
scan the money's going all over the
world to people in finance even
government you are a problem God damn
right I'm a
problem no way he's coming to a street
through the back entrance I figured i'
give The Firs a break somebody need to
tame this
guy
die we have to kill him before he kills
his way to the
top
honey it's flammable as [__] who
knew going
get
ready to come work for Uncle Sam Secret
Service
Daddy get some sleep okay I need you
fresh tomorrow what happens tomorrow one
of my agents called in sick you're on
Air Force
One Dam I break this one in yes
sir it's all yours General it's the
president sit back and enjoy the rides
let's CLE Z off this now first we have
to take the pl back remember kid you
only have one job protect the
president Air Force One this is Andrew's
Air Force based air traffic control
please acknowledge
over Air Force One come
in oh my
God we're still gathering in Intel we're
coordinating the search for Survivor for
bodies mam vice
president
Hi you Flame the king of agent my one in
at a
time now tell
me do you think I'm
lying
yourself What's
[Music]
happen sooner or later he will make a
mistake and it'll be the last mistake he
ever
makes
whatever you have to
do however long it
taks promise me you'll find your way
home
fosa give me this
[Music]
promise
lady and gentlemen
start your
engines
I'm furios the darkest of
Angels the question
is
do you have it in you to make it
epic 19 states have suceeded the United
States Army ramps up activity the White
House issued warnings to the Western
forces as well as the Florida Alliance
the three- term president assures the
uprising will be dealt with swiftly let
me know if you want to try anything are
you guys aware there's like a pretty
huge civil war going on all across
America we just try to stay out with
what we see on the news seems like it's
for the
[Music]
best citizens of America the so-called
Western forces of Texas and
California have suffered a very great
defeat at the hands of the United States
military Mr president do you regret the
use of air strikes against American
citizens we moving to thec today we need
to go down there they shoot journalists
outside in the capital every Instinct in
me says this is death
what every time I survived the war zone
I thought I was sending a warning home
don't do
this but here we are there's some kind
of misunderstanding here what we
American
okay okay what kind of American are
you you don't
know the Western forces will reach the
White House on July 4th oh my god get in
the car get in the
car move move
move you're going to hang back
I'm not hanging back one
nation under God
indivisible with
liberty and justice for all go go go go
go God Bless
[Applause]
America
[Music]
welcome to my
world for most of human
civilization you we believed that life
could only
exist on the surface of our
planet what else we WR
about still
this world has more
secrets
you have to save yours and our
reputation the DEA murders in Silverado
remember that yeah two undercover agents
killed in a drug bik we're
DEA I got the marshals to agree to send
you down and bring those two witnesses
back
[Music]
here sometimes I mess around with movie
lines you looking at me mhm there nobody
else around
[Music]
here got a doctor fix you up the right
way
this is my brother it's dangerous the
longer we here the more danger for your
family Joon has a few lives left he's a
strong
one she can help so who killed those DEA
agents in America we can protect you
can I saw what happened that night and
they know it
so who do you know that you trust that
you can
call so many questions my
friends if you want to fight with the
Wolves you got to be a
[Music]
wolf
for
[Music]
foree
a
wooho
spee
speech
foreign
why hold a brick in my
hand I know exactly what it is and what
it will
do this form is its
function that gives me
peace can I help you I'm the brick
layer sir this is urgent what am I
looking at Victor radic we need to bring
Vil out of
retirement what do you want and an old
friend stop by to say hello someone's
trying to Blackmail the CIA you can
bring down our entire Global
Network that's why I want you to go to
Greece to fix it with her it's a big
assignment for you first time in the
field no
supervisors I'm the supervisor of course
you
[Applause]
are
so what's our move I have to find him
and end
this you should have stayed where you
were cuz now that you're
back it's going to be hard for you to
leave again
clearly I warned you not going to get
involved
you can't hide from me I'll never ever
stop
[Music]
coming oh little L colone next time yes
dear
we're going on a man hunt not building a
chimney never do a job without my
tools hey come on get your stuff let's
[Music]
go
let's try that
[Music]
again a week ago I spent my life racing
against time I'm going to help you out
today okay trying to save people who are
running out of it get until one
moment changed
everything come on Welcome Back to the
land that we're
living I don't understand what's
happening I've been having
Vision I knew he was going to
die I think I'm seeing the
future New York City is a whole new
level of crazy these days what do you
want New York City is a whole new level
of crazy these days this is an emergency
get off the train that man's trying to
kill you why who are you what is going
on I can see the
future oh what the hell she didn't see
that coming that's not how it
works I've seen that man before so who
is he Ezekiel Sims he was in the Amazon
with my mom when she was researching
spiders right before she
died wait I recognize you you live in my
building you're the paramedic yeah you
almost ran me
over you don't think this is weird how
we're all
connected it's honestly like the least
weird thing that's happened all
day you have no idea what those girls to
[Applause]
come I think he can see into the
future he's trying to change what
happens jul you get
down why aren't you scared of me why do
you me your future was almost so
different if you want to live you have
to trust
me get
ready
now you're showing off maybe a
little
it's okay I'm here I'm here it's been a
while since you've had one of those
nightmares tell me what was it
about it's only
fragments nothing's
[Music]
clear you've been fighting the hinin for
decades
lo my family's been fighting them for
centuries your blood comes from Dukes
and great
houses here we're
equal what we do we do for the benefit
of
[Music]
all I'd very much like to be equal to
you maybe I'll show you the
way deal with this Prophet send
assassins fade rather he's
[Applause]
psychotic I see possible Futures all at
once and in so many futures or enemies
Prevail but I do see a way there is a
narrow way
through
[Music]
my allegiance is to you you believe
me this is a form of power that our
world has not yet seen the ultimate
[Music]
power I want you to know I will love you
as long as I
breathe you will never lose me as long
as you stay who you are consider what
you're about to do for the TR is
Sil this prophecy is how they enslave
us
got you are not prepared for what is to
[Music]
come
Peter
Barrett excuse me my name is
Sophia and my mom called you Peter
biometric watch contains a hard drive
with sole access to his contacts stolen
Intel and we want it all back she wanted
you to find someone named Peter my
name's Mark I wish I could be more help
you were CIA like my mom right you're a
really good painter oh hey kid stop
those are private this is her this is my
mom so you do know
her go upstairs BL AR left the bathroom
lock the door and get in the
tub what's
[Music]
happening you are Peter Barrett how'd
you find
me what do you know about Peter Barrett
the painter Bo murdered eight federal
agents in Cold Blood what I am looking
for
someone it's me Peter where are you can
I trust you two agents showed up my
doorstep today asking about
you he's hiding something you're the
only one who can protect you tell me
about the people who came to kill me she
thinks thinks that you're in possession
of something that poses a major threat
to our national
security I'm going to find out who took
your mother away from you and then and
then he'll do what he does mind if I
borrow a few
[Music]
things
I don't want to do this
[Music]
[Applause]
kid I'm telling you it's going to be
another hot one out there in fact there
are heat alerts in effect for New Jersey
feeling like
100°
leaving me here on my
own what is
that
for the first time in New York history
people froze to death in the middle of
July what is it the death chill
the power to kill by fear
itself your veins turn to rivers of ice
your bones crack and the last thing you
see is your own tear GTS freezing
up like literally scared to death so
[Music]
cool
[Applause]
my son never show
Mercy they are
PR
we are
predators boys your mother is
dead she died because you sent her away
she was weak sick in her mind you know
my business
yes power is about
strength if you show
weakness you will give our enemies an
opening sh
shut he is weak like his mother leave
him what happened that
day I stared death in the face and for
the first time I saw my true
self tell me about this
Hunter they say he uses a connection
with animals to track his
prey once you're on his
list there's only one way off the six of
us the only one of you there's six of
you
[Music]
now why do you hunt my father put evil
into the
world I take it
[Music]
out think give some kind of Honor we
were exactly like our father just
another man hunting for a
trophy
murderers isn't that what he taught
us you don't get to do that to me
anymore Mr
tlin Mr
tlan where's Mr T oh you're standing in
him
you're a goddamn lunatic oh you just
figure that out
now there is an animal I need of us
don't you want to know why they call me
the
rhino
everyone wondered how the world broke
we're under
attack deep down before Society
collapsed we were already falling over
the it was only a matter of time before
it all
crumbled try to hold your breath hold
your breath I saw this so what it might
be nuclear are you
scared America's just been attacked get
to the homestead is this an ark or is
this a
fortress it would take a miracle for
this to work but I believe in
miracles everyone wants to know how the
world
ended this is the story of how it began
again
[Music]
oh hey Dan happy
anniversary Dan my husband he's an
amazing dad you almost ready to go to
size four rest huh are you so big look
at the big musos I just wish our lives
were
bigger really at least let me put my kid
Down clean up on a six sorry about the
mess hold
on oh hey b hey
Dan don't hang up I need no identities
I'm burned me my wife and three kids
have you told them yet I'll tell them
when I'm on the road meet me in Vegas in
3 days this is crazy look my God we're
going to
Vegas woo oh so pumped nothing brings
the family together like a road
trip stop collaborate and listen I is
back with a brand new invention
5 hours on a plane or 33 hours in a car
can someone unlock the car
please go and
everybody I want him
found what was that little pothole
Maxi's been up the whole time by the
way wish that
before I met your mom I was a covert
assassin I escaped at life and now they
found
us what
the being your husband and their father
that's the real
me you're like James Bond in a minivan I
love that
minivan I need to be that guy one last
time for
us baby look at you Blain of family man
I'm not playing is my
life hey I'm kind of into spontaneous
St wait wait
[Music]
go new
record I'm not an enforcer I'm more like
a um a
fixer
exactly I have to convince a certain
person person bu in that trunk out there
is indeed Rolo something happened to his
face what the it's Miss along with the
rest of his
head betrayal is a funny thing it's very
naturous to catch you
unaware you ever heard a ring
doorbell we're under
attack stance
gone and you should be too I had one
rule s be good to the people who were
good to you be good to yourself Charlie
and get as far away from here as you
can you turned on your own you ought to
get out of buuy char that's what
everyone keeps telling
me that 50 Grand could really change
things for me I'm going with it without
[Music]
you ass Charlie I got more men than you
got bullets bullets are easy to get
what do you want you not breathing and
how you going to do that I'm doing
it you know you really ought to start
thinking about an Exit Plan what are you
waiting
for pull the trigger
[Music]
Charlie you're in over your
head I don't like loose
hands
theut them
down you my second best guy I'm looking
forward to meeting number
[Music]
one 4 years ago I was basically
unemployed a Wanderer with no
home but now I'm a husband and a
father and I wouldn't have it any other
way I'm I do pops my job was a little L
stressful than
yours oh yeah I finally got a job I'm
the king of
[Music]
Atlantis half a billion people from
every known species in the sea call this
place
home but that doesn't mean they all like
me I'm going to kill Aquaman and destroy
everything he holds
dear I'm going to murder his
family and burn his kingdom to
ass he must be stopped for a global
meltdown is
imminent I think I know someone might be
able to help us who o you look
rough good job little brother High fire
do not call me
brother I cannot believe you let this
happen yeah well I hate this job true
king built Bridges
right true king builds
Bridges we need to find Manta he's
different now he's stronger than
before it's the black
Trident during King Alan's time there
were Seven
Kingdoms and the Trident was a curse
upon them
all the tridon start magic is
spreading he means to end the
[Music]
bloodline I don't know what lies ahead
but we can't leave our children a world
without
hope you know how is as bad at this as
you
think if you lead the Seven Kingdoms
will
[Music]
follow